[Music]
the department has found
and recaptured the majority of the
today we turned the tables on the other
side that's a nice quote
and this is lisa monaco
[Music]
ceo
[Music]
five four
for today
[Applause]
so we want uh
now
them
yes
yes
how are you thank you so much
that's right
it's all right um
thank you
it's like
yes
one one more right there that's all this
control the other side
one right
yes thank you
move
so where do you want this one put this
one right here
thank you
[Music]
all right guys uh thanks for coming
today i'm marc rimandi's two minute
warning
we're going to get started uh in just a
minute um
the flow of show will be deputy attorney
general lisa monaco will kick us off
a couple minutes remarks followed by the
fbi deputy director paul abot
followed by the acting u.s attorney for
the northern district california
stephanie hines
and also on stage will be the assistant
attorney general's for
national security and the criminal
division john demers
and nicholas mcquaid we'll follow the
remarks with a couple q a
and then we will uh wrap it up
all right uh sound checks everything
working out everybody hear us
all right be back in two minutes thank
you
from
so
so
uh
good afternoon thank you all for being
here
today the department of justice is
announcing
a significant development in the
ransomware attack
on the colonial pipeline i'm joined
today
by fbi deputy director paula bate an
acting u.s attorney for the northern
district of california
stephanie hines to discuss the work of
the department's
ransomware and digital extortion task
force
in combating the epidemic of ransomware
attacks
by criminal groups also with us
our assistant attorney general for
national security
john demers and acting assistant
attorney general for the criminal
division
nick mcquaid ransomware attacks
have increased in both scope and
sophistication
in the last year targeting our critical
infrastructure
businesses of all types whole cities
and even law enforcement
ransomware and digital extortion pose a
national security
and an economic security threat to the
united states
the department of justice working with
our partners
is committed to using all of our tools
at our all the tools at our disposal to
disrupt these networks
and the abuse of the online
infrastructure
that allows this threat to persist
the sophisticated use of technology to
hold businesses
and even whole cities hostage for profit
is decidedly a 21st century
challenge but the old adage follow the
money
still applies and that's exactly
what we do after colonial pipelines
quick
notification to law enforcement and
pursuant to a seizure warrant
issued by the united states district
court for the northern district of
california earlier today
the department of justice has found and
recaptured
the majority of the ransom colonial paid
to the dark side network in the wake of
last month's
ransomware attack ransomware attacks
are always unacceptable but when they
target
critical infrastructure we will spare no
effort in our response
darkseid is a ransomware as a service
network that means developers
who sell or lease ransomware to use in a
tax
in return for a fee or a share in the
proceeds
darkside and its affiliates have been
digitally
stalking us companies for the better
part of last year
and indiscriminately attacking victims
that include key players in our nation's
critical
infrastructure today we turned the
tables
on dark side by going after the entire
ecosystem that fuels ransomware and
digital extortion attacks
including criminal proceeds in the form
of digital currency
we will continue to use all of our tools
and all of our resources
to increase the cost and the
consequences
of ransomware attacks and other
cyber-enabled attacks
the seizure announced today was
conducted as part of the department's
recently launched
ransomware and digital extortion task
force
which was established to investigate
disrupt
and prosecute ransomware and digital
extortion activity
this is the task force first operation
of this kind
this work is important because every day
the digital threats that we face are
more diverse
more sophisticated and more dangerous
in this heightened threat landscape we
all have a role to play in keeping our
nation safe
no organization is immune so today
i want to emphasize to leaders of
corporations and communities alike
the threat of severe ransomware attacks
pose a clear and present danger to your
organization
to your company to your customers to
your shareholders
and to your long-term success
so pay attention now invest
resources now failure to do so
could be the difference between being
secure now
or a victim later
but also know that we are all in this
together
the u.s government will continue to do
more
to increase our nation's resilience
while increasing
the costs to our digital adversaries and
those
that enable or harbor them and we cannot
do so
without you the department of justice
will continue to evolve
as the threat evolves
that is why one of the first acts
i took after returning to the department
was to launch
a strategic cyber review that is why
federal prosecutors now report
ransomware incidents
in the same way that they report
critical threats to our national
security
and that is why we will continue to work
with our public
and private partners both here and
globally
to bring our collective authorities
together to confront
emerging threats there is no higher
priority for the department of justice
than using all available tools to
protect our nation
that includes from ransomware and other
digital
threats thank you and now i'll turn the
podium over
to deputy director paula bate
thank you doug monaco good afternoon
everyone
today the fbi successfully sees criminal
proceeds
from a bitcoin wallet that darkseid
ransomware actors use to collect a cyber
ransom payment
from a victim since last year
we've been pursuing an investigation
into darkseid a russia-based cyber crime
group
the darkside ransomware variant is one
of more than 100 ransomware variants
that the fbi is currently investigating
darkside developers market their
ransomware to criminal affiliates
who then conduct attacks and share a
percentage
of the proceeds with the developers a
scheme known as ransomware as a service
in this case the fbi has identified more
than
90 victims across multiple u.s
critical infrastructure sectors those
include manufacturing
legal insurance health care and energy
based on our investigation into dark
side and incredible work
with other u.s government partners we
identified a virtual currency wallet
that the dark side actors used to
collect a payment from a victim
using law enforcement authorities victim
funds were seized from that wallet
preventing dark side actors from using
them
this is just the latest disruption that
the fbi and doj have taken
to impose risks and consequences on
cyber adversaries
since announcing our new cyber strategy
last year we have dismantled the
infrastructure
of the ematete criminal botnet through
an unprecedented coalition
of u.s and international law enforcement
and private industry partners
additionally we have joined other
government partners
to expose a cyber tool developed by the
russian gru
we have also used legal authorities to
remove malicious backdoors
installed on the networks of microsoft
exchange server customers
across the united states in just last
week doj announced the seizure of two
command and control domains
used by the perpetrators of a wide
spearfishing campaign
this focus on joint action and
collaboration
is exemplified by the national cyber
investigative joint task force
which brings together intelligence
community law enforcement
and cyber security agencies for a whole
of government approach
against these cyber threats our partners
in the intelligence community
and across government are central to
these efforts
leveraging each of our authorities and
capabilities
enable us enables us to conduct
coordinated operations to respond to
and deter malicious activity from groups
like darkseid
there's a lot of exceptional
behind-the-scenes teamwork
that goes into both identifying
effective ways to target adversaries
and predicating actions that we may take
against them
i want to give major thanks to the
incredibly hard-working
special agents intelligence analysts and
professional staff
of the fbi's atlanta and san francisco
field offices
and the fbi cyber division along with
government-wide partners
who assisted in this investigation and
seizure
these cases require a significant level
of determination
and technical expertise and without a
doubt every individual
involved displayed that through the
achievements reflected here
today we continue to be committed to
using the information intelligence we
develop
through our investigations to take early
meaningfully
meaningful steps to protect the public
and be preventative
we will continue to work relentlessly
and seek innovative ways
to use our unique authorities
world-class capabilities
and enduring partnerships for maximum
impact
against our adversaries today
we deprived a cyber criminal enterprise
of the object of their activity
their financial proceeds and funding for
financially motivated cyber criminals
especially those presumably located
overseas
cutting off access to revenue is one of
the most impactful consequences
we can impose when the fbi combines our
law enforcement and intelligence
authorities
with those of our partners in government
and the cooperative relationship with
private industry
and when we have victims willing to
share information
to further our collective efforts
against cyber adversaries
we can have immediate permanent effect
on ransomware actors
that is why it is so critical for
victims to report intrusions to us
as soon as possible and then work with
us to provide evidence
and intelligence for our investigations
leading to recovery attribution
and ultimately prevention victim
reporting not only can give us
information
we need to have immediate real world
impact on the actors
it can also help prevent future
intrusions into other victim networks
and prevent further harm from occurring
with continued cooperation and support
from victims
private industry and our u.s and
international partners
we will bring to bear the full weight
and strength of our combined efforts and
resources
against those actors who think nothing
of threatening public safety
and our national security for profit
thank you and i now like to invite to
the podium
the acting u.s attorney for the northern
district of california stephanie hines
i want to thank deputy attorney general
monaco for inviting me to add my remarks
last week deputy attorney general monaco
spoke about the onslaught of ransomware
attacks
being carried out and suggested we all
should focus
organized resources on meeting this
challenge
as the acting united states attorney for
california's northern judicial district
i am directing my office to continue
to marshal the resources necessary
not only to apprehend and bring to
justice
ransomware extortionists but also to
deprive them
of the profits that incentivize their
crimes
today we announced the seizure of
millions of dollars
in bitcoin paid by an innocent victim
in ransom in a bid to regain control
of computer systems the extortionists
will never see this money new financial
technologies that attempt to anonymize
payments will not provide a curtain
from behind which criminals will be
permitted
to pick the pockets of hard-working
americans
this case demonstrates are resolved
to develop methods to prevent evil doers
from converting new methods of payment
into tools of extortion for undeserved
profits
the northern district of california is
home to silicon valley
an area that year after year
fuels remarkable innovation and
expansive economic growth
in the technology sector as the nation
increases its reliance
on technologies developed within
and exported from northern california
so too do we increase our reliance
on law enforcement to develop maintain
and employ the expertise necessary to
keep our technology
safe criminal actors employ
aggressive complex tactics
to attack our infrastructure and our
daily lives
and increasingly can do so from anywhere
on the planet
our efforts to disrupt and deter these
threats
must be creative and advanced
i want to thank our partners at the fbi
for their professional deployment of
expertise
and for their skill in coordinating with
the prosecutors in my office
and with our colleagues in the criminal
division uh components
to allow us to reach this result i'd
like to turn the podium back over to
deputy attorney general monica
thanks stephanie okay i think we're
ready for a few questions
how much of the money did you take out
of this bitcoin account that you found
did you
clean it out basically and is it the
first time the government has ever done
this
so it's not the first time that the
government has
ever seized cryptocurrency in connection
with ransomware attacks
this is the first um such seizure
that the ransomware and digital
extortion task force has
uh undertaken uh with regard to your
first part of your question pete
um i'll let the court documents speak
for themselves they lay out
the probable cause that was presented to
the northern district uh to the judge in
order
in the northern district of california
with regard to the tracing of the
um criminal proceeds to the dark side
actors
sarah hi i i was wondering you know does
this mean you know
based on this example for other
companies when this happens to them
does this imply that they should also
pay if it's through cryptocurrency
because
of the blockchain technology and the way
that the fbi was able to
track the money and seize it i mean is
that a tactic that companies should
consider
the the message we are sending today is
that if you come forward
and work with law enforcement we may be
able to
uh take the type of action that we took
today to deprive the criminal actors
of what they're going after here which
is the proceeds
of their criminal scheme we cannot
guarantee and we may not be able to
uh do this in every instance so
the point here is there's a very
significant undertaking this was an
attack
against some of our most critical
national infrastructure
in the form of the colonial pipeline and
this represents the swift whole of
government response represented in the
work of this task force
and our determination to go after the
entire ransomware criminal
ecosystem used by these types of
criminal networks and their affiliates
which are targeting
uh and going after including in
disruptive ways
our critical infrastructure alex davis
thanks um so i guess when you boil down
the figures though they're still
technically walking away with
roughly two million dollars in
cryptocurrency payments here
so i wonder what you say to that
argument that the deterrent factor
really isn't here in this case because
this group is
based out of russia and because of that
isn't really likely to face criminal
consequences for these actions
well i'm not going to get ahead of the
investigative efforts and the full
consequences that associated
uh with this ongoing investigation but
this represents the seizure and
deprivation
from criminal actors of exactly what
they're going after which is
criminal proceeds of their scheme and it
was
swiftly done based on and thanks to
um the quick notification by colonial
pipeline their work
uh with the us government uh and the
message here today
is we will bring all of our tools to
bear to go after
these criminal networks including the
ecosystem
and the elicit and the abuse frankly
of the online infrastructure that they
use including digital currency
to perpetrate these schemes all right
thank you very much if you have any
additional questions please send them to
me
and we'll get them answered for you have
a great day thanks very much
thank you